morning. We are back
live.
Hi. Plan for today is to continue
working on
release. Got a good hour and a half,
hour 40 right now and uh
thereafter be back for a good chunk of
the rest of the
day. I really want to get the final
experiments done. Um, there are a few
things that are still weird with the
hyperparameter
sweeps, and I want to figure out
why. They work generally pretty darn
well, but they don't work exactly the
way I want them
to, right? So, we have a few different
things to look at here. So the first one
here this
experiment. So what I did here is I
changed the way that clipping works
quite substantially.
Okay. So, this is actually slightly
worse. I'm
coefficient. So, here's the F
coefficient.
clip? All right. So, this doesn't even
really get used. So what I tried to do
here, I reformulated the
clipping process a bit
differently and it actually it does a
fair bit worse. Now the one thing I do
want to look
at, let me just compare one thing here.
This is like 21 22 seconds,
right? We've also got these experiments.
coefficient. We have a lot of these runs
down at the lowest possible end. What I
want to do here is I'm going to do a
filter. We're going to do VF clip coat.
clip and we're going to set this to be
less than or equal to
0.1. Okay, so now we only have 93
runs. And if I look at these
time. Okay, so we actually still do
have like 19 or 20
seconds. It is still
better. Like if we have 19 or 20 seconds
over
here for a full solve with 93 runs and
then if I take this filter
here. It's just that this one run got
kind of lucky. I
think I think we can still set like a
20-ish second solve even if we prevent
it from doing like ridiculously
aggressive clip.
Can we do
um we take a quick look at
like if there is a substantial
correlation like we actually have good
runs at any clip co-op. I guess we can
do like
time less than 25
Most of the really good runs over here
are just at the lowest possible
odd. All
right. So, we have uh we do have that
for
starters.
Oops. And now we want to look at our
maze
results. Yeah. So, this is like this is
quite substantially better than
before because we we did this sweep and
we did this sweep.
other like the same
curve. Tiny bits of shifting.
steps. This is actually probably like a
uh an eval problem,
right? Like it not getting an accurate
evaluation maybe.
Well, I mean, this is not surprising
that this hasn't done particularly well
then. And we have to figure out why it's
locked to
uh to so
Is this like
BPT Horizon or like numbum M's too big
or something
weird? Pick one of these.
steps. Becknum Ms is
four. I think that's
large. Yeah. So, it actually does have a
bunch of M's.
Still batch
size. Batch size is
auto mini
batch. Small mini batches.
Okay, we can uh we can get some ideas
for runs from here.
So, I say we limit VClip. Hang
on. Let's actually do some of this
stuff. Oh, hey Linky. Hey. Uh, hey
folks. I uh I didn't have the chat up.
One second.
I can only see it on this little tiny
experiments.
Curious. Okay. Link is just saying
puffer. Curious why you didn't join a
lab or do a posttock but still building
puffer li full time.
Well, I mean, I made my own lab
basically, right? Like I'm doing my own
thing here. I don't want to do a
posttock because the whole way that I've
gotten all this stuff done with Puffer
is to move very very far away from the
way academia does work.
Um, yeah, that's that's pretty much it.
Like it's really a postoc is just not an
appealing position at all either, right?
like you get paid nothing anyways and
like you have academic obligations and
the only thing it lets you do that a PhD
doesn't already let me do is like go to
a professorship position which I have no
interest in like why would I do
that and like existing labs aren't doing
the thing that I wanted to do so I had
to do my own thing Okay.
Oops, not this one.
We're going to set this to 0.1. One.
actually just go grab some
uh some defaults to
use. Got
like gradient norm, right?
and the main thing I wanted to do was
the
evals. This eval function that I have is
not very good.
Yeah. So, this needs to have like a
pretty decent
sized additional eval, I would
Wait, this is and not
stats. This should be
ore. Yeah, there should be
ore. That's probably all it
was cuz
like 64 time steps.
25. This should always be reasonable. I
think if I just do
this. Okay. So now what do we do
additionally for breakout?
This actually maybe changes the uh the
sweeps a little bit already. I'm trying
to think if there's anything else we can
do on breakout speedrun
specifically or if we're kind of just
good. Do I believe that this is capped
out? I mean, I can sweep the uh this the
frame skip,
right? We have not tried free sweeping
frame skip.
Yeah. So, frame skip can go 0 to 5, 0 to
6, something, 0 to 8, whatever.
Okay. So, that actually should produce I
think that's worth running these as uh
as new experiments now. Like these
should be
substantially different results.
Welcome YouTube folks. We are looking at
the results of last night's experiment
and launching some new ones here.
Okay, the goal kind of um with what I'm
doing at the moment, I'm just sort of
fine-tuning our sweep
stuff, there like a bunch of little
things I wanted to test that could make
a difference just so we have our
strongest possible results for uh for
launch. I'd really like to have um a sub
202 set of breakout parameters in
particular. I think that would be very
nice. Like a consistent solve in sub 20.
That'd be pretty
way. Let me go look at the to-dos now
because I think if I spend a third day
in a row just working on blog post, I'm
going to go nuts.
And I also I want to make sure we
getting the rest of our stuff into a
good
spot. Hey Linky, did you finalize
merging release into dev?
Yes, it's in dev.
The new end bindings you can look at
like snake or neural MMO. Um it should
be quite easy to bind in most cases. If
you find yourself doing like weird
Python API C API stuff, you probably are
over complicating it.
And once we have the final sweeps here,
we really just need to do like the add
ones, drop
ones. The few things that still bother
me, I don't know if we want to
have the 10 points per
run, like the down sample
trajectories. We probably do
You know, we probably do because like
the
um cosign and nailing should give you
pretty darn smooth learning curves. So,
I think it's fine to have to have
that. Give release a look over and seem
pretty clear. Yeah, I'm trying to make
it very simple. The hope is that the new
release should be very very simple.
It's like I almost shoot myself on the
foot because like I work so hard to make
it look simple and then if you don't
know any better in RL people go well
that's easy like you know why is he
working on this forever if it's that so
easy it's like well it took a lot of
work to make it this easy for
I finally got like an actual coffee
maker as well for here, which I've
wanted for a while.
now. We need to lock in like a good set
of
defaults and we need to run some sweeps.
A little weird how uh neural MMO doesn't
sweep
right. Uh it's possible there that just
the search centers are not very good.
I think I have a tendency to like just
kind of agonize and stew over um every
release and I want to avoid doing that
as much as possible. I'm trying to think
like what really things I want to have
done in order to like cap this off. Like
I got to move some files around and do
some pretty minor cleanups.
I think probably just the process of
running all the
I'm trying to think almost if it's worth
like
um am I if I'm ready to just like run
all the dang experiments and be done
with it.
Like do I just spin up a whole bunch of
extra
machines and just go for it?
No, I don't I don't quite think so
because there's still
like there's still like little extra
annoyances around that I like I don't
feel like we perfectly understand quite
everything yet on this.
I think what I do is I assume that I am
going to keep the 10 down sample points
thing
um for protein. That's probably a good
idea.
Well, I think that's probably a good
idea at
least. I don't know if I should ablade
it or not.
The maze sweeps in particular bother me
because like the maze sweep domain is
the one where it should be really darn
good and I thought I actually had
something on this before. Can you access
a PNG in an asset folder through an
import? It might be nice to have all
puffer assets.
um you get into relative path
things like you can't just import an
asset folder like import from Python.
You can give it the
path but then you get into relative like
path
issues. They're not in the end folder
though the puffer assets linky. They're
in uh resources.
Like there's a resources folder that has
some shared ones and then it has like
some uh some MS specific ones.
this
external m clean
up move uh brand files.
That's pretty much
it. I just installed puffer lip pip.
Yeah, I'm also I'm going to
um I'm going to move the train stuff
into there as well. So, it's like you're
literally going to be able to have like
a one one command or whatever to do it.
should be quite
good. I know I definitely just need to
like a whole bunch of experiments to run
is the
thing. It's not even that I don't want
to spend a few hundred bucks on like
compute over the next week. like that's
not a big deal. It's that I don't want
to have to deal with like spinning up
and tearing down machines and like not
knowing if they're undervolted and like
whether the PF is actually reasonable or
not.
Um, but there's actually there's quite a
bit of stuff I'm looking now that I'm
looking here that like I can kind of
just
do cuz we still need to clean up all the
external M's and make sure stuff runs.
We still need
to we need to clean up the configs for
those as well. We need to move some
train
files. Quite a bit of stuff we need to
do. And honestly, like all the
deprecated ends that nobody
uses, we can get rid of those as well,
right?
We keep like Majoko, Atari, Procgen, and
like the other ones that people actually
use. Okay, so I think we start
by I think we actually
runs. What other like random files do I
have in here? I guess I've got like the
C++ and
Let me just look how uh how torch
extensions does
builds. There's like some name conflict,
isn't there?
I think the easiest thing is going to
just be to like do
their like their annoying extra step
with either make like put them each in
their own folder or something.
See? Yeah, it's pretty
decent. We've got this
Damn it. That is not what I meant to do.
Me go get my code
back. Yeah, I think if I do some of this
cleanup work today, this will be good
because I'm sick of writing. I kind of
want to just do some code and move some
stuff
around. This will be
better. I lose a lot of steam when I
spend too much time on like fiddly
fiddly bits.
There we go. Yeah, these need to be in
different folders for whatever reason,
even though they have different
extensions. I don't know. It's kind of
weird.
Reasonable. Oh, just train by
default. M should pop or break out.
Let's do this.
Ah,
shoot. What is uh this giant
So, want to see what the root structure
looks like.
I still have all this
stuff. C advantage.cu and
anymore. Yeah, we can get rid of all
this.
What else do we not
need?
SP3 of
that SBC advantage.
UN.Py. We don't use
this. Well, it's not committed
anyways. GPU drive test.
I'm going to get rid of these files and
Spencer can yell at me if he needs
them. Evaluate ELOS.
Don't use
this. I just
made you have thread.
Gotcha. I'm happy to help stuff if you
get stuck on things. Like a lot of it is
we need to have uh we need to have all
this stuff like cleaned nicely so it's
I'm just thinking about how I want to uh
do it specifically.
Yeah, I don't want to like look
everywhere for binding files though. I
think I only want to look
Hey, there's your oneliner that gives
you uh your binding files, right?
Okay. So, this does
this. Um, I think
that I might be able to like get auto
rebuild to work. But yeah, Linky, that's
a good suggestion. Thank you. I'll often
like I'll take the idea, but I'll just
want to like implement it a little bit
like
simpler. So like you know this is the
oneliner that'll look for binding.c
anywhere in any of the ocean
subdirectories but I think this does
what you want. Yeah.
We'll see how that goes. And now if I
refresh
this, got a lot less crap in here.
And that looks
good. It gives us our export
Yeah, we really didn't end up needing
this very much,
huh?
Anything we don't use, we get rid of.
That's the rule.
Okay, so this was supposed to be some
sort of test for new bindings.
visualize. Use this
either though. We'll probably end up
taking some of this back at least.
Okay, so now we just have
setup.py com license. Yeah, now we all
just have the standard
stuff. And now we have config, puffer,
lib, scripts, and test.
Now, I don't think that this config can
live here is the problem,
right? Cuz like you're not going to have
access like this is not going to get
packaged up for
you. So, I think we have to move the
config into puffer lib, right?
Unless there's a way to tell.
Um, no, there isn't. If it's just if
it's not in here, it's not in here,
right? So, we have to do we can probably
sim link
it. Hang on. So we do like get
move config upper lib.
everything. Is it What's the sim link?
Is it the
desk? Okay, let me double check. Set an
alarm for a meeting. I think it's in a
couple hours,
though. Welcome, YouTube folks.
I think I've got breakfast in 30 and
then I got a meeting at like 11
something. Double check this and then we
will keep working on this for a bit.
folks.
11:30. Me set myself an alarm for that
and then we will
finish the
right. I always forget the sim link
syntax.
lib. Got two sim
links. Got the
readme. If I open puffer
lab, we have a few things in
here. Fairly small.
This definitely needs to be here. This
probably needs to be here. This needs to
be
here. Yeah. Now we actually we
have this is a pretty nice file
structure. I'd say this is a pretty nice
file structure.
I wonder if it makes sense now to put
the configs files with the source here
or if it makes sense to separate
them cuz like before you know we weren't
shipping the config files.
I think we'll like leave it like this
for now and then we'll we'll think about
It still
runs. This still runs
named
Jim. kind of
silly. Oh, yeah. That does need gem,
doesn't it?
required project.name is not set. Okay.
So there's additional validation I
guess.
require. Yeah, this is not what I Why
the hell you be using uh this version?
It's weird that this is failing in like
something that should not even get be
getting imported at
all. Python tooling system just
is We'll just like pin We'll just like
pin 312 default.
Definitely a lot of packaging stuff I'm
going to have to figure out with this.
But
um the main thing is now at least the
files are in a reasonable spot and we
can start looking at stuff like the
entry points and like how we're going to
want people to be able to
uh to use Puffer just from the pit
package.
It should be pretty
helpful, All right.
I don't know what it thinks it's
installing here.
There are like several things I just do
not like here.
How the heck is this still
failing? Now we're failing on
Oh, this is probably cuz it's build
time,
like this is why you don't import your
your version string like
requires. So I guess a lot of this has
to get moved to the toml for the toml to
Yeah, this is like so stupid. I think
you have to like duplicate the damn
version. We'll do stuff for now, but I
remember the TOML setup just being kind
of
dumb. Is this just because of this the
thing in the TOML?
Okay, this is what we were looking
for. The setup.py version.
And this actually seems to
run. I don't know why the hell it's
installed. It's uh trying to break my
CUDA now. That's kind of
obnoxious. Requirement already set.
Okay. Okay. So, it didn't reinstall CUD.
It's just really really slow in
checking. Fine. Cool. So, what we'll do
is uh I'm going to go for breakfast. I
got a meeting afterwards.
Um, and then in the afternoon I will be
back and the goal will be to get
packaging in a good spot today, get all
of the uh the things where they should
be, get entry points the way they should
be, kind of do all that side of things,
probably move some code around quite a
bit, and uh yeah, I think that that will
have us
in a bit of a better spot for uh for the
release as well. Cool. So, uh, thanks
for tuning in. All my stuff's free and
open source. Usually I'm working on
actual RL and not packaging
RL. This release week for you. Um,
puffer.ai. start to get up to help me
out